(intense wind)
(atmospheric music)
(airplane motor)
- Other people would laugh at me.
In fact, all my friends say we worry
about you Dilys, you know.
I think even coming out this weekend,
somebody said oh no be careful.
I think that's ridiculous.
What a better way to die, having fun.
I am a world record-holder
for being the oldest
woman skydiver in the world.
I think, if there's
only one way, it's down.
So even if I've got
slight absent-mindedness,
I'll be alright.
I don't worry that my
carpet is rather threadbare
and old, as long as I'm skydiving.
But I do get scared.
I used to be so scared
that I would drive the car
up to the drop zone and
think, I could go back.
I don't have to stay here.
But I knew if I went away,
I'd never come back again.
So, so the ecstasy was more than the fear.
(airplane motor)
The first time I jumped
out of an airplane,
I thought I was going to die.
And as I fell, I thought,
what a mistake, this is death.
I can remember it now.
And then the next second,
I thought, “Oh, I'm flying.”
(upbeat music)
Skydiving gives you the most
intense, wonderful feeling.
I mean, people come down from a jump
and they all say, “It's better than sex.”
I mean, take that the way
you like it, but it is.
I think sometimes we
get pulled down by fear,
we get pulled down by necessity of work,
and it's a mistake.
That having done skydiving,
I learned courage.
I learned to go.
And that has been the biggest
turning point in my life.
And I think the courage
has helped me to run
a charity, which from
scratch is very difficult.
They say most charities
fail after three years.
And I knew that I had a program
that affected for the
good, very profoundly
disabled people and made
them really much happier,
and that thrills me.
I believe we all have a purpose in life.
And I believe that Touch
Trust is my purpose.
I don't have much time
to think about the past.
I'm so busy in the present and just going
into the future, that the past recedes.
And I am enjoying so much
these days remembering
the past, remembering
even the difficult times
that seeing how they
all fell into a pattern,
which now I'm glad of.
You are a bird for 50 seconds and imagine,
you can go 140 miles an hour,
you can do a barrel roll.
You can flip, you can move
here, you can move there,
you can join up with people.
It is unbelievably wonderful.
I won't stop, until I know it's not safe.
But for now, I'm safe and I can do it,
and I will do it for as long as I can.